hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to until done now I
think this this is gonna be interesting
because I'm pretty sure this guy is
actually on their side yeah
is the monster yeah I thought so oh wow
spine broken in Tenma ow gut broken in
10 million pieces oh okay now this make
more sense because I was pretty sure
that guy was reaching for the twins in
the beginning of the game and I was
pretty sure that guy was probably gonna
be good because he's trying to poop yeah
I did it it's still bright let me stare
directly into it yeah it definitely
wouldn't burn my retinas to ash
I really feel like I should have hit
Josh in the frickin face but also I
don't know if violence is probably the
answer because I maybe if I would hit
Josh it would have been more satisfying
and instead of just uh but it did disarm
the situation that kind of played the
smooth down and to be honest Mike didn't
seem like he had his cool he has every
reason to be pissed off it uh H Tanner
pissed off at Josh and probably a little
homicidal so you know you never know
what's gonna happen
everything's butterfly effect that just
yet Rodi Rodi Rodi Rodi let's try to
find if there's anything good over here
to see cuz willing to bet willing to bet
willing to bet that there's gonna be
Saha here we go
yep what do we got here Calgary Billy
Billy where have I heard Billy before I
know about Billy Billy was before post
guard of Calgary with a romantic message
on the back Billy was part of the crew
that blasted new tunnels deep into the
mine Billy Bates blasting crew Northwest
mines Alberta hey Billy I had a great
time look me up if you're ever in
Calgary
Loretta Lou kiss kiss kiss I'm sure
that's what that means well I bet they
hugged a lot oh hello there anything I
need to be worried about over here
so now that the story is piecing
together and makes a bit more sense
because I was pretty sure like people
were saying that there were two monsters
and there were two things going on two
separate things happening it doesn't
look like there's anything else over
here so I guess I got dropped down so
now that's revealed that there is a
monster on the hill which seems to be
quite the coinkidink when there's Josh
who's totally unhinged and unstable but
hey you can't win them all I guess you
just have to make do with what you got
let's drop down without killing
ourselves now shall we thank you
well it's quite a drop good thing you're
needed and just explode out of its shell
all right so what do we got here I keep
hearing these monsters wonder if I'm
gonna have to defend myself probably the
answer is yes and now that I know that
flamethrower man is actually a cool
chill dude named Billy probably or
something maybe not Billy may be the son
of Billy now that I know he's a cool
dude I should be of all that's a told
him I think that's a totem that's
definitely a totem come here you told
him that white-white may be good yay
okay so Mike had a tough decision to
make
all right so Mike didn't do something
and got frustrated for it I'm guessing
that's not killing the mr. Josh man and
I'm really wondering if jessica is
actually dead or just fakie wakey fall
down a shaft dead dead cuz I don't know
if there was anything that I could have
done differently to make jaw or Jess not
die I have a feeling there's gonna be
more to it than that with Mike having to
go rescue Jess because now that josh is
totally unstable but now there's the
mystery of maybe hannah is still alive
somewhere you just don't know where
there could be something interesting
going on and if my understanding is
correct then John
nothing like it I knew you'd I wonder I
see you okay so I'm willing to bet that
the miners unleashed a monster somehow
and it's been no no no I know doctor I
didn't want to do that yet go back god
damn it I wanted to explore a bit more
piss your fire at it ah ah [ __ ] there
was maybe a clue there was a clue here
right there was a map of the mines
there's a map of the mines mine danger
map okay so if I could look closely
excu it was a risk of collapse I just
crossed over a bridge now I don't know
where the bridge would be I just had a
thought that maybe okay but there's got
to be like a bridge I can't see anything
here it looks like it all paths the
right way might be bad so I'm going to
go left
hmmm that's just my guess at this point
I really have no idea what else I could
possibly do so left left left it is Oh
circus elevator
Oh Oh I didn't even know I was running
towards the surface elevator Oh is there
no power
oh there's not gonna be any power sir oh
good oh oh good well that's quite
fortunate
maybe but somehow I bet the game will
find a way to make it not fortunate
which is gonna be good for me I am so
happy
Oh Horton row row row
oh I didn't even know how I was out of
stop whoa okay that was a long time
coming
whoa okay oh [ __ ] no okay we'll just
ignore that one ever happened oh oh
that's enough maybe
okay
I don't know how you knew that was gonna
be a thing that you needed to do maybe
you'll see a little faster a little
faster would be nice
stay on stay on go go go that's how you
face
Oh barely meowing holy crap yeah blocky
Oh God
lucky lucky oh wow that was an explosion
about feeling badly it's just the words
run about your flies where am I going
fun-filled adventure now I'm surprised I
can still hold on how but broken I
mention em all my bones are broken and
somehow I'm still alive cuz that's a
cool thing I like that Wow emily has
been through some [ __ ]
yeah you better still go Emily has been
through some [ __ ] but I got her out
alive somehow maybe I don't know maybe I
will maybe I won't where'd she come from
where'd you go
birdie I'm glad they shot me up because
I what I didn't want to keep going
yay safety crap what now uh-huh one now
veteran quick so the door oh my god shut
the door yeah I'm okay are you all right
I didn't think that I'd make you're
[ __ ] me you'll totally water was
somewhere to that Cub Scouts house some
things that I do there along turns away
wait okay em are you okay first be
concerned okay I'm fine I don't feel
anything I just need to calm down it was
moving so damn fast okay I just had to
get away from this thing whatever it was
I think you can relax Josh was messing
with that not listening to me wait okay
concerned yeah where is Matt no way em
where's Matt is he okay no use the cable
car so we climbed the tower and then it
fell and we were down in the mine like
way down down in this terrifying freakin
mind shelve on hold on
and and then it was Matt and me down
there and oh god I think that Matt might
be dead
wait what oh Emily what happened I was
walking down there in the mines and it
was dark and I found this pile and there
was Beth's head wait what that's head I
found my god what the [ __ ] you serious
yes I'm serious I think they fell down
there oh Jesus Christ
but the worst part is I don't think that
Hannah died like from the fall not right
away
what what do you mean I don't know I
feel like she was down there like
starving to death for weeks when we were
all up here looking for her we had no
idea
so how was Emily able to get out in a
hurry mind you in the tower there was
there was a radio and I got through to
someone but then that was right when the
tower collapsed am
you made it God what about Matt we're
trying to figure that out never there
was this monster that was chasing her
I've she's all messed up guys
Emily hey em whoa [ __ ] happy
Josh Jess this is a flame for a man to
flame through a flamethrower sorry
close one guys fighting how is flame
through a man fighting a one-man war
against these monsters this whole time
without anyone ever noticing yep it's
him
sure is him all right I trust him he's a
good guy in my book he's a ok don't
shoot him wait wait ok ah ah my goods if
I demand it from him I don't if I demand
it from him fight demand it from him
Mike not give it to me but in my
premonition Mike had it anyway so I'll
be supportive I'm gonna just go guard
the door
ok don't open the door
ready ready just do it already whoever
it is is probably calming I'm no easy
guy no no no think that's less good I
got the gun does the gun keep changing
from a revolver to a pistol all right
huh oh no I check it out hold on Oh God
I'm just so tense we're okay here we go
whoa ha ha
hold on there hold on there mr. freeze
oh all right just douche okay everybody
just calm down
thanks bro grandpa gram bro
grandpa bro I'm here to tell you
what you're up against being back on
this mountain you should never have
returned I don't know why you did after
what happened last year
you mean with Hanna and Beth yeah how
could you know without being involved or
responsible you hold onto your horses I
don't take kindly to you kids coming up
here to my Mountain your mountain huh
I'm sure the Washington's would be very
surprised to hear that
well the Mount don't belong to me it's
true but it don't belong to the
Washington's
the washing just belongs to the wendi-go
Oh Oh is he talking about the hell's a
Wendigo let's hear him out now like we
have a choice now I'm only gonna tell
you this once he doesn't matter to me if
you believe it or not kill I got reasons
I want to get it off my chest
see I told you he's guilty as [ __ ]
guilty of something Mike yeah Mike there
is a curse loose that dwells in these
mountains
not the crazy mountain man or woman
resort to cannibalism in these woods the
spirit of the Windigo shall be unleashed
oh crap
oh good you brought a memory you're safe
the basement might be okay
okay get down there now all of you on my
way but why how long till dawn guys I
ran off and left Josh when I heard
screaming where did you leave him in the
shed ah your friend will already be dead
no no yeah yeah we were just with him a
lot can happen quickly on this mountain
no I'm gonna go get him you can't go out
there Chris I'm supposed to be his best
friend and I let him down no he let you
down Chris he let all of us down I don't
much yeah okay Chris you being brave
I'll go with you
yeah you're going on his suicide all
right the rest of you get down in the
basement be safe don't go outside again
until we're back you don't seem to
understand the magnitude of the
situation
thanks crazy dude well I'm going to get
Josh all right no I'm going to get Josh
you're going to help me do you
understand me yeah I think so you need
to follow me and do everything I tell
you everything you tell me got it that's
very explicit in what the game wants me
don't deviate from my own choices being
autonomous robot I've got it I'm the
expert at being that thing oh my god
it's the shoes gun I saw a plain notion
about this where's the thing you want to
kill I know how to use a shotgun man no
you don't what how do you know trust me
I know
I was using rifle down the burger before
you got it
ah I don't think that was the right
sound to make in that situation isn't it
I I did more of an aggressive emotional
moment these things Oh what's uh what's
a guy got to know he just be careful you
follow my lead
you got a buddy bang oh no oh god I
didn't know how to use a shotgun how
many times do I have to shoot it with
the shotgun before it's dead well you me
shooting it a long time yeah you mean
this thing won't even kill it messy boy
seems a little strange
kill it they don't like fire I don't
like fire they fear it and I can kill a
man if you have to their skin is like
it's like tough armor unless you burn it
off first
thanks Greg how did how do you know this
your little freaking me out man all this
freaking me out right before I do this I
have to hit pause real quick because
there's some butterfly effects here that
I want to go after Ashley was grateful
and felt indebted to Chris Josh felt
betrayed and antagonized by Chris good
I'm pretty sure that's the way it was
supposed to that Chris considered
violence I didn't even have a choice in
that I tried not to
Josh felt betrayed what we all felt
betrayed that's a bunch of baloney there
who has a gun I know that Emily had a
defense against oh wait a minute here's
those onions I didn't even use it bunch
of Bologna
alright see Chris hit Josh because the
psycho gave him the black eye which is
totally understandable
didn't she Ashley was concerned about
Chris as he left so he got a little bit
of kissy whoo yay once bitten
Emily was bitten oh no I didn't know
that was the thing that happened and now
she's hiding out with the rest of them
oh boy all [ __ ] on resort
cannibalism weird what are these things
like I mean are they just crazy
unpredictable or I mean can you figure
out what they're gonna do
they'd hear some patterns mmm like a
animal or human yeah you mean like how
like they've got schedules well they
only hunt at night oh oh good I didn't
ask
is this a new totem or did I find this
before I have no idea I'm gonna count as
noon till proven otherwise Pro Wendigo
tips no you smell me or something
they're still smelling you anything like
that I can't see you here standing still
it's like toads sight is based on
changing the movement in their field of
vision thanks buddy
so if I don't move I'm basically
invisible yeah I wouldn't recommend
testing it out
how do you know all these things this is
captain exposition over here he's just
narrating the entire plot of the story
oh my god it's mr. plod device walking
around with his plot divisive
flamethrower see the connection from the
flames earlier in the game he was trying
to help all along now he's here to
explain why we're dumb Wendigos are were
human do they still have some aspect of
humanity
the important question certain things I
mean is it really right to kill them
maybe they can be cured they surrender
human rights the moment they eat one
another there's no cure there's no
redemption III mean if there's still
human I don't know if it's right to hurt
that when you're scaring one in the face
it's them or you you feel free to take
the high road you won't be on it for
long understood buddy saves 10 for Roger
Rooney I'm all on board this train to
hell I can't wait to go down to the
sanatorium take up some pills enjoying
the jaws parade in its fun-filled
adventure oh boy when will the nightmare
stop I hope that oh hey here we go well
that don't look good
something tells me what happened maybe
got out he's gone we're too late
we gotta go right now we gotta find Josh
he can still be out there
first when you go you'll render you I'm
a while
he strips the skin off of your entire
body piece by piece he keeps you alive
and aware and feasts on your organs one
piece at a time
so for watch that
so you just might not be alive and I'm
all about to this one time this guy
actually trusts other people and goes
near other people I'm gonna go wait I
need to go explore back in here because
it's like the first time that I've been
able to get back in here so I want to
see what this is all about I mean if we
just come back in here maybe we'll
discover that you've been not dead all
along
yep dalchi's scout/guide yeah yes yeah
oh my god
what everyone else is around here Neil's
availa you want to get shot getting in
the face I'm a Chris on the edge I don't
got a lot of brave points but I'm very
charitable with my bullets yeah anybody
want a lid sandwich I'm cooking up a
nightmare I can't go beasted okay here
we go
what about you I forget it forget what
forgive and forget
I completely agree we should just carry
along it's gonna be weird knowing that
all this was filmed some erotic weird
door porn going on here
yeah oh okay
quiet you need to stop doing that one up
oh I didn't do nothing
I didn't do nothing right I didn't be
closing oh come on
max god damn right out you gotta get out
of here of course of course
oh no whoa [ __ ]
Captain Blood device no I [ __ ] you oh I
should have hit the explosives I didn't
know that one was this is aiming for
well that wouldn't have been wave answer
what duckie dude suck it with your tough
armor skin now from the souls of dead oh
oh that better Oh Peter
Emily fell down a million miles into a
mineshaft boink
goodbye you're gonna get me again with
you again with your baloney what's that
of it
what did I get it I think I might have
gotten it thank God for shotguns Fred oh
okay God please let me a quick hey Chris
oh my god what happened yeah we gotta go
that thing was like right behind me
as expected captain plot device didn't
last more than 10 minutes I had a funky
feeling he was gonna be all funky fresh
oh no Josh no oh god no Josh Josh
oh man Josh oh mmm Chris where's the
flamethrower guy huh yeah oh god yeah
yeah I tore him apart I didn't find me
Oh God
all right these all the doors yeah are
you sure what do you look this is my I
detect [ __ ] face I really don't
think that's a good idea
no wait that's my that's my seduction
tilt on at least we're safe down here
oh yeah I'll wrapped up like a little
present with a bow on top for that thing
to tear us apart on Christmas morning
people will come for us in the morning
I'm not so sure Emily did manage to
radio out what will happen right em yeah
I mean right well you can wait I'm
leaving Mike there's no key for the
cable car Josh he's got to have it Josh
on his dirty little tricks great great
if that [ __ ] thing got ahold of Josh
then we should had a lot yeah it did so
how about you don't go anywhere
what's possible it may have taken him
down to the mine what I saw some
horrible stuff down there I think it's
where that thing lives and huh
um oh look at this thing I found that's
gonna further the plots gonna get that
key right from that things goddamn
bedroom and then I'm gonna get us all
the hell out of here
good job Matt Mike sorry it's got you
confused with the dead guy that old
guy's bag is that a map oh I was
prepared for anything
not quite this is this place oh my god
yeah what is that I was down there it's
horrible you are some of them survived
but like 15 of them didn't make it
I found these plans they knew the mine
was a deathtrap but they let the miners
keep working anyway Michael I'd like to
maybe focus on how we're gonna get the
[ __ ] out of here please
thanks em cuz I know you're back in
normal forme heard how much crazy shits
gone on up here what's weird is that
there's a tunnel leading from the lodge
to the sanatorium see that's how I got
back here I saw this when I was down
there that's where it lives um um what
is huh what is that ash oh nothing me
and Mitch you what bit you bubs the one
to go what it's nothing really it's not
a big deal okay [ __ ] it doesn't hurt
anymore really it's it's not that bad
em if that thing big I I know what
you're thinking and I'm fine
are you yes Emily at least let us check
it out she hasn't cannibalism Windigo
bit you you could turn into one of those
things it's ridiculous he said it was
from eating each other remember he said
that is that how it worked yes it
happens if it be you you're gonna turn
into one and then you're gonna turn on
us oh my oh yeah let's not freak out
here here with us Oh what is this
baloney what is this
putting us all in danger I know it works
like that maybe it's just a bite I've
seen what these [ __ ] can do I don't
want to say it again
what is this guys what are you doing
doors right here I am letting you do
this voluntarily oh no you're just
making yourself feel better about
sending me to my death since you know
there's a one to go out there ready to
rip me to pieces like it did with okay
oh my god you just go go get out of here
well okay whoa whoa Mike calm down
you're gonna shoot me like me this is
the same room em exactly I'm safe as
long as you're in a time really sorry
Hey look a picture oh my got a pretty
butterfly
wait butterfly butterfly effect of
course you can't just stupid idiot
you're frickin dumb you doofy Doo maybe
there is a food keep an eye on her if
you see anything weird you guys know
what to do yeah
no one leave okay yeah it's safe out
there
oh really I'll be back soon thanks for
your leadership bro you're the best here
I thought you were totally chill with
Josh but apparently new I'm glad I
didn't hit Josh now what a bunch of
fools this turned Indic this went from
like totally normal
evolving what is she doing she's like a
freaking predator here I thought that
that he was gonna help us with a
flamethrower dude now we don't have a
chance
Oh guys it just means we've got to be
tough we've got to do this on her own
okay whoo we got stuff camp lism okay
hang on
whoa okay so that's all over this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching we're gonna get the rest of
this let's just summarize my thoughts
people be stupid
and now the story got stupid cuz mr.
plot device walked in and then oh the
first time he's been surviving for years
and years hunting Wendigos gathering all
this knowledge about the wound goes and
oh no Oh Mike Oh I'm a gun-toting loser
you're gonna die you're like a werewolf
cuz I've heard about this thing just now
and I'm an expert I'm gonna blow you
away
oh yeah yeah whatever now I'm gonna go
off on my own
cuz almost done and why the Frick not so
thanks everybody so much for watching
click the annotation more videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye
that's how you're gonna play this game a
game baby I'm home come out and scare me
Oh bye yay nothing rocked out you
staying for a long time everything all
this week every year I wake up